hey this is preshtalwalker this is a
variation of a puzzle i posted about a
year ago
there is a long single file line outside
of a dance club
the first person in line is unmarried
and the last person in line is married
each person in line only looks at the
person in front of them
is a married person looking at an
unmarried person
the answer choices are yes no and cannot
be determined
surveys have found that approximately
eighty percent of people
cannot get the correct answer in a
version of this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the short answer is that the first
person in line who is married is looking
at an unmarried person
the answer is yes
now since many people cannot get this
correct answer i'm going to go through
the logic in detail to show you why this
is true
so we'll number the people in line from
1 to n where 1 is the first person in
line and n is the last person in line
let's consider person two
if person two is married
that person two is a married person
looking at an unmarried person one in
front of them
so that would lead to the answer of yes
however we do not know whether two is
married so we have to consider that two
might be unmarried
if that is the case we then consider the
next person in line three
the logic is going to be the same
if three is a married person then three
is a married person looking at an
unmarried person to in front of them
otherwise
three is also unmarried
so we then proceed to the next person in
line four
we can continue this logic to check each
person in line
the first person that we find in line
who is married person k
is looking at an unmarried person k
minus 1 in front of them
now we may not know if any of these
people are married
in that case
all of the people in line 1 all the way
to n minus 1 are unmarried
but in that case we know the very last
person in line n
is married which means that person n is
a married person looking at an unmarried
person n minus one in front of them
therefore the answer is yes
there must be a married person looking
at an unmarried person
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshellwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description